[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the sorting hat
harry potter voldemort and horcruxes
more specifically
we're going to be discussing whether or
not during the sorting ceremony
the sorting hat detected the piece of
voldemort's soul
inside of harry the sorting ceremony is
a rite of passage
at hogwarts school a tradition that has
existed
nearly since the school's inception the
purpose of the ceremony is simple
assign students to one of the four
hogwarts houses
in order to do this a magical sentient
hat
called the sorting hat is used a hat
that once belonged to hogwarts founder
godric gryffindor the sorting hat when
created
was instructed to sort students by how
closely they resembled
one of the four founders and because of
the powerful magic
used to create the hat it possesses the
ability
to navigate the layers of the wearer's
mind seeing things that even they
themselves
may not know to perform its task of
sorting students
the hat uses a magical ability known as
legitimacy
which is the art of magically navigating
through a person's mind
someone who is proficient at practicing
legitimacy is referred to as a
legitimate
which is essentially what the hat is a
master legilimens
but my question is if the hat is so
knowledgeable and so good at unraveling
the layers of someone's mind
then did the sorting hat know that a
piece of voldemort
lived inside of harry when harry was
first sorted
the hat was conflicted it wasn't sure
where to put harry
it wasn't quite a hat stool meaning the
hat requires more than five minutes to
decide
but it was close and it really didn't
know where to put him
gryffindor or slytherin hmm said a small
voice in his ear
difficult very difficult plenty of
courage i see
not a bad mind either there's talent oh
my goodness yes
and a nice thirst to prove yourself now
that's interesting
so where shall i put you harry ends up
in gryffindor but he was very close to
ending up in sutherine
i can't help but wonder was harry only
nearly put in slytherin
because of what the hat detected in
voldemort's soul fragment
or did he possess slytherin-esque
qualities in his own right
one important thing to mention is that
harry isn't actually a proper horcrux
i've explained this in previous videos
but essentially
he's not a horcrux because voldemort
solshard didn't enter harry
via the traditional horcrux creation
process
this is explained by jk rowling here's
the thing
for convenience i had dumbledore say to
harry you were the horcrux he never
meant to make
but i think by definition a horcrux has
to be made intentionally
so because voldemort never went through
the grotesque process
that i imagine creates a horcrux with
harry it was just that he had
destabilized his soul
so much that it split when he was hit by
the backfiring curse
and so this part of it flies off and
attaches to the only living thing in the
room
a part of it flees in the very close to
death limbo state
that voldemort then goes and exists in i
suppose it's very close to being a
horcrux but harry did not become an evil
object
he didn't have curses upon him that the
other horcruxes had
he himself was not contaminated by
carrying
this bit of parasitic soul i feel the
need to make this distinction
because whether or not harry is a
full-blown horcrux would certainly have
some sort of bearing
on how the hat analyzes his mind
horcruxes are inherently dark
receptacles
and harry though he bore voldemort's
soul did not possess the same
dark properties furthermore according to
rowling
the sorting hat did detect the pieces of
voldemort's soul
when analyzing harry's mind i always
imagine that the sorting cat detected
the presence of that piece of soul
when harry first tried it on because it
strongly tempted to put him in sutherin
so that's how i see it however the hat
primarily detects
thoughts and feelings at this stage
harry didn't even know that a piece of
voldemort lived inside of him
so it's hard to imagine that possessing
voldemort's soul would have had
too much influence on the hat's decision
i imagine that if harry was a
full horcrux then it would have been a
different story
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you